so we lost with the Germans again well I
have to take it okay so first of all
thank you to the Academy of course I'm
very happy that you appreciated a movie
that concerns an important issue for
Poland now in a hidden way talks about
an unjustified fear of the other of the
different and who knows that who knows
then knows because not everybody knows
what's going on in our country but
that's important for us Wow those lights
are strong I really want to thank of
course my crew it's mostly was made of
women so one of them is here tonight so
thank you Sousa for being here she's the
cinematographer and up and there is a
man my husband who is the scriptwriter
he said he's a woman today I don't know
what that means but I should get scared
and all the other talented people Yulia
the main actress who's not here with us
so I won't say all the names of course
thank you to the Polish National Film
School who gave me the opportunity to be
here to all the professors and the
promotion because that's why we're here
they decided to send us here and and and
that was a good decision thank you to
the Polish Film Institute and I want to
dedicate this award today to many
political issues sorry but that's what's
concerning us on these days today we had
a demonstration in Poland because
against intensifying the anti abortion
law the government is being quite strict
on us so this is for all the people who
went out on the street today thank you
very much